so the next game game started it
went
quickly 2300 yes I've had that
several times too let's take a
look so double
fchetto let's see what he does with D6
he builds up and knight D7 yes
a lot of queens do that E8 yes he really wants to
move E5  Well, okay,
I can take knight D2 comfortably now aha
okay, so that gives a quality, let's see
if he gets something for it
D8 of course also has disadvantages
as you
can see, just make sure that
something doesn't get weak on the black squares,
maybe that's okay  Let's take that
away E4 E3 is still a black
plan, well I can draw E3 myself and
stop it, well okay, I'll take that.
Runner B4 should have maybe done C3 or A3.
The runner coming in there might
not be so
cheap, well, but prevent it  Let's see that
now the D is getting a bit weak but
I have to do C2 with it
so that C2 is okay, he has runner
E2, he has gotten a bit of activity,
well
everything looks forced so far,
so of course I have to get rid of the D3
somehow, of course
it actually works
only with bishop F1 but well first of all
rook
D1
yes if I change the bishop to the 3
the white squares will of course be extremely
weak. An idea would also be
to move B4 and the knight to D4 yes
I actually like that quite a
bit on D2 he has it  just really no
future,
well, but black definitely has some compensation in this position,
so C5
maybe okay, now I'll support myself
carefully. C5 was clear, yes,
now I'd like to completely encase it in concrete with C4,
well, I'd like to at least go to C4 to D4
if so  he pulls it
so clearly now it's on
D3 in there and I ca
n't get rid of it so quickly with F3 I could
at least nibble on it WE is
of course very
weakening, well he ca
n't do that much A4 A5 could  I want to
play ah I want to play bishop G7,
maybe
take it away okay but that's not
dramatic so the gut wing is the
first
question is whether you should perhaps play F3 now
yes I can't get any further without
the move
probably t the bishop on die3 is of
course exceptional
strong, put the queen differently
yes yes black actually has compensation yes yes does
n't help anything I can't leave it standing on i3 all the time
yes he plays very
directly
but that also makes F5 weak
so if I take bishop
H3 good okay
E3 yes okay me  I want to win so
somehow I have to open the box
so now you have to see that
you can get something on F2 on F5
I'll try A2 F2
of course I don't have much time as
usual well with that C1 tower
F2 yes well
the whole position  Looks a bit
shaky, hope nothing direct
works
somehow, we would have managed that before,
of course it's positive that he
had to pull the knight back
because F5 is under so much pressure, but I'm
already on
top of it, small reinforcement move ah yes,
now I want the king there  insert well,
I'll go with the one with my own
on the
side
so well time
warning look maybe we can
open it somehow it's hard to see well I can
I could play I'll do it
Runner F4 is definitely bad it
does the whole box
up and then maybe take rook G2 F2
I think it would always be good for
me even if knight would take it,
yes, that's what he's doing
now okay, I'll stand on F5
on it so
so I had to move a little faster
so but I could take it with me  I got
thrown out with H3
or could also go to H4 does
n't look bad either.
He prevented the queen
so if I take it now and
H3 actually looks like that
should be good. I now also have a
good knight against a very bad
bishop  I just don't have anything on the
clock, he can't play tower G7 because
F5 is stuck. The position is now very
good for me, but I have very little
time, only 20
seconds left,
so luckily he has to take a
longer break now,
so here comes it  Rook on the
hairline
Check so tur8 threatens
I hope Queen H5 now the threat
Check
Check so now I have to accelerate a bit
but luckily everything is white for him
so he can never
hit anything okay that's just resign in the end
yes  Technically
I don't think I played that well. After the
quality win he got a lot of play
but somehow with tower F4
that was still a good idea, yes
it was probably still okay for
me